a lot of people Pat reacting very
strongly to some of the recent uploads
of posts i've made to my Instagram
account at david pakman let's start with
one of my favorite spots here in the
Boston area michael's delhi i was there
over the weekend and i had a reuben now
as a as a vegan Pat and we can keep the
picture up are you familiar with the
infamous Reuben sandwich I mean I've
heard of it I don't know what meets in
it you don't know if there's a special
kind of bread that makes it a Reuben
you're going to have to tell me about it
typically Reubens are either
pumpernickel as pictured here or rye
bread would be the other way to go a
marble rye can be a nice in between and
you've got your Swiss cheese of course
it's corned beef based sauerkraut and
russian dressing there's also a version
of it called the Rachel which replaces
the sauerkraut with cole slaw which some
people like I love deli food and I but
this is actually at Michael's deli in
brookline massachusetts which is a
classic stop for me and I didn't know
when I posted this that people have such
strong feelings about deli food and yeah
people are very particular about their
delis it almost looks like seafood like
it's lobster or something the vegan says
that my Reuben looks like seafood
alright make a note of that folks also a
popular fixture over the weekend I got
together with some fellow Argentinean
and I was tasked with handling the
frying of empanadas now empanadas an
argentinian food staple i am partial to
the oven baked empanadas not only for
health reasons pat you'll be pleased to
know but I just like them better I don't
like the overly crunchy fried empanadas
but I was in charge of handling the
frying of some of the empanadas although
I really focused on eating the oven
baked ones and people really like this
they were interested in my tongue
technique of course being left-handed as
some people shocked that I was holding
the tongs in my left hand but everything
I'm seeing in this picture makes a lot
of sense to me I don't know what you
think so they were both fried and
oven-baked they were about did some of
each
absolutely if these were vegan would you
prefer fried or oven baked I mean it was
a special occasion I would go for the
fries I have nothing against that I make
falafels sometimes and I cry though I've
actually read about oven baked falafel
sounds horrible but ya know falafel you
you really have to have it fried all
right follow me on instagram david
pakman big food weekend as people can
tell all wrapped up in what's going on
there